Wurf, Abschlag vom Gegner und Spurt –
und vor allem immer wieder
Kopf einziehen:
Der Ball kann schnell werden, bis zu
160 Kilometer pro Stunde.
Cricket wird eigentlich auf
gepflegtem Rasen gespielt.
Aber Kapitän Irshad Ahmad vom
Team des MSV Bautzen
ist schon glücklich über die kleine Halle.
Hier sind Leute aus Pakistan,
Afghanistan und Indien.
Sie sind alle gekommen, um
diesen Sport zu spielen.
Wenn sie kein Cricket hätten, würde
das bedeuten, sie hätten gar nichts.
Stolz präsentieren sie im
Flüchtlingsheim ihren ersten Pokal.
Viele Spieler sind erst seit
Kurzem in Deutschland.
Sie warten auf Anerkennung
als Asylbewerber.
Aus dem Flüchtlingsheim kommen
sie nur selten raus.
Es kann auch gefährlich werden.
Ihr neues Zuhause ist Bautzen in
Sachsen mit seiner 1.000-jährigen Altstadt:
eigentlich hübsch –
hässlich dagegen, wie sich hier immer
wieder der Fremdenhass entlädt.
Im Februar legten Unbekannte Feuer in
einem Haus,
in das Asylbewerber einziehen sollten.
Im September skandierten
Rechtsextreme zwei Nächte lang
gegen Ausländer und Flüchtlinge.
Auch Ahmad und einige seiner Freunde
wurden schon bedroht.
Wir trafen auf eine Gruppe von 40 oder
45 Männern in schwarzer Kleidung
mit Bierflaschen und Baseballschlägern.
Sie sagten: „Geht weg hier und kommt
nie wieder hierher.
Das nächste Mal lassen wir euch nicht
entkommen.“
Dann sind wir abgehauen.
Nach dieser Nacht hat Irshad Ahmad
lange mit sich gekämpft.
Kann ihm diese Stadt eine neue Heimat
werden, trotz der Fremdenfeindlichkeit?
Er hat entschieden:
Ja – zumindest vorerst.
Wenn ich wegen solcher Sachen immer
und immer wieder flüchten muss,
dann wird es für mich sehr schwer,
in dieser Welt zu überleben.
Da ist er eben ganz Sportsmann,
einer, der sich durchbeißt,
und Cricket hilft ihm dabei.
Heute treten die Bautzener gegen
eine Mannschaft aus Tschechien an –
kein leichtes Spiel.
Das gilt auch für die Regeln beim Cricket.
Man kann sagen: Eine Mannschaft wirft,
die andere schlägt den Ball
so weit wie möglich weg.
Aber das ist nur eine von vielen Optionen,
bei diesem Spiel zu punkten.
Cricket ist in Deutschland
eine Randsportart.
Durch die Flüchtlinge
ändert sich das gerade.
Im vergangenen Jahr lösten 40.000 neue,
zum größten Teil gut ausgebildete Spieler
aus Sri Lanka, Afghanistan oder Pakistan
einen Cricket-Boom aus.
Die Zahl der Teams hat sich
fast verdoppelt.
Der ehemalige deutsche Nationalspieler
Volker Ellerbeck sieht riesige Chancen –
auch für seinen Club.
Wir haben unseren Verein dadurch
wieder besser aufgestellt.
Wir waren sozusagen am Ende
eines Zyklus.
Wir hatten viele gute Spieler verloren
in den letzten Jahren
und haben jetzt viele junge, neue, hungrige
und sehr talentierte Leute dazugewonnen.
Das Team aus Tschechien hat zwar
auch viele Spieler aus Südasien,
aber keine Flüchtlinge, die es
regelmäßig verstärken.
Das macht den Coach der tschechischen
Mannschaft etwas neidisch.
Während Angela Merkel fast jeden
reinlässt ins Land,
lässt unser Präsident alle draußen,
und das ist hart.
Wir haben keine Flüchtlinge.
Die kommen zwar durch unser Land,
aber nur, um weiter nach
Deutschland zu reisen.
Irshad Ahmad will sich in Deutschland
integrieren
und mit Cricket eine Brücke bauen.
Dabei helfen ihm Schüler und
Lehrer aus der Region.
Sie unterstützen die Cricketspieler,
suchen Plätze und Hallen,
helfen bei der Organisation der Spiele.
So hoffen sie, Spieler und
Einheimische zusammenzubringen,
aber das ist schwierig.
Wir haben schon Interessenten gehabt,
die sich das einfach mal anschauen wollten:
„Was ist denn überhaupt Cricket?“
Viele kannten’s nicht und sind einfach
mal interessehalber stehengeblieben.
Und es gab aber auch schon die Situation,
dass Leute da waren
und sich am Training beteiligt haben.
Und ich denke,
das ist doch ’n guter Anfang.
Der MSV Bautzen siegt an diesem Tag
gegen das tschechische Team.
Und jeder Sieg hilft den Flüchtlingen,
sich in Bautzen wohler zu fühlen
– trotz allem.
Sie haben etwas, das ihr Leben jetzt
wertvoller macht.
Und außerdem können sie all die Dinge
vergessen,
die sie auf ihrer Flucht erlebt haben.
Einfach Spieler sein und nicht mehr
nur Flüchtling: Das ist ihr Rezept.
So wollen Kapitän Ahmad und sein Team
gegen den Hass auf alles Fremde
in Bautzen anspielen –
und wenn möglich gewinnen.